[Music]
yep
he was last seen last night so
you could get all your guys out of there
what's that
[Music]
oh yes thank you
[Music]
hello there
oh don't worry about that we'll take
care of that for you okay
i had a cigarette louie
i really need something to drink okay
well i got my doctor pepper on the
counter okay okay we'll give you one
second don't bring a bite
on what who is he to you boyfriend yes
because for like three and a half years
what happened he and i we drank last
night we had can you pass this to the uh
around to the fb you guys stop they need
to sign that for sure
no no each of them has to so this might
be a real thing so each of them has to
put their names
i just put everybody
yeah you call her it's working um what's
going on sorry i just got here so fill
me in no problem
putting the pencil together
you are putting a puzzle together yes we
have a puzzle that we started in there
okay we've been doing art turned taking
stuff off the wall to make new art put
up there like having a good time with
one another but we're drinking we had a
bottle of wine last night okay so then
it's like
we decided to play hide and seek right
okay so he gets in the suitcase okay who
is this guy that's my ex-husband my
former husband how did he live here with
you guys no i called him over here okay
okay i didn't know what to do okay i
didn't know what to do okay so then he
came over here here let's talk and
private okay i called you guys
i tried giving you guys
the problem is is i fell asleep
i fell asleep when did you do cpr this
morning
when i found it before you called yes
it's one o'clock right now
i tried
i was awake but i actually got out of
the bed at like 12 30 ish whatever so i
came downstairs
and i was like oh
he's in the suitcase still
that's when i found him and i took him
out and tried doing cpr and then i
called him and then i called you guys
did he get here before the fire
department got here your husband or your
ex husband
you're okay i don't i wasn't here i'm
just trying to figure out what happened
i fell asleep so i don't know if he's
suffocated or like had an aneurism or a
heart attack or what kind of medical
conditions does he have and none that i
know of nothing that you know
no no no
all we had was a bottle of wine
literally just a bottle of wine okay
doing puzzle artwork then we decided to
play hide and seek
that's all that happened okay
so i don't know if he had a heart attack
or what in there like i don't know what
happened so how long were you doing cpr
on him prior to you calling 9-1-1 you
tried that all morning yes okay and then
i called him while i was one time did
you start probably giving me a ballpark
here let me fill this deputy in okay
please marry my dr pepper i am
ma'am and you can't talk to him until we
get down with different okay just don't
leave okay ryan thank you ma'am
thank you
i know do me a favor stand over there by
that car give me one
need please i need water
okay i'll get some for you trying to
charlie put you on it
[Music]
so kind of tell me how you came here
today or
well i've been um
[Music]
about a year and a half
about 11 30 is when i started calling to
find out because this is supposed to be
her day
64. okay she's generally not very good
about always doing it
they called back and said she was still
finally got a hold of her uh
what was going on and if i'd come over
here so i came over she caught it at 12
45.
yeah
12
um got over here told her she
needed to call 9-1-1 get somebody over
here
and then uh basically she said she
needed to go outside have a drink and a
cigarette i walked back out the house
because
who
i
did you call or did she call well i
called she called me back when i was on
my way to make sure i was coming up
but um
i called for it one second okay
i called her initially you have water in
your car
by any pants
[Music]
nothing okay okay no i don't okay so she
calls you get
i got my stuff together put the puppy up
in this crate um when i was starting to
drive over here is when she called me to
make sure i was coming and then i got
over here right now did you go inside
and see and then i i walked inside the
front um i didn't need the little front
tile area come on step this way i
thought leg
well just for the sake of the crime
scene i want to know if i were to find
your footprint it would be because you
went this far into the house so did you
actually make entry i don't think
threshold i don't think i ever made it
to the carpet i think it was just in
that um
i've been over here before right right
right yeah but um no i don't think i
stepped past that
tile area okay so um
i touch door knob
i don't think i touched anything in the
kitchen i don't know that really matters
okay so that's pretty much the key to
what you have we'll sit tight for us um
we're gonna make a few phone calls and
then we'll go from there you know if he
has any metal uh medical issues or
[Music]
for the two of them
[Music]
really okay i'm not familiar with
i haven't been here personally it's so
they haven't he's currently on parole
because of it so um because of domestic
violence with her yes okay okay yeah
from the last time he got um
retrials something or other
he had to go to a um domestic violence
class i know he was doing at a parole
officer
stuff like that but i mean like every
time she'd have arrested the next day
she was trying to get bailed out so
i i don't know what it is oh she's
getting water from the tab she's
probably gonna pass out on us
okay well listen please let me
try it i'll make it not a problem i mean
would your kid need to be picked up
uh lakemont elementary how soon though
uh three o'clock three o'clock
let me try and get this going for you
because i know you need that
martinez
i'll just go ahead and start making the
calls sam could you go ahead and give me
his last name for us spell it for
me and his first name george j-o-r-g-e
j-o-r-g-e-j
o-r-g-e
his birthday
2 13 78
and this is the boyfriend yes
how long
uh three and a half years living
together that whole time yes okay and
your last name boom spell it d-o-o-m-e
first name sarah s-a-r-a-h
birthday
10-10-7-7
so you've had a second to kind of
collect yourself tell it to me again you
guys were playing last night drinking a
bottle of wine putting patches together
doing artwork puzzles artwork i had a
bottle of wine and then decided to play
hide and seek so what time was that do
you remember
i mean i know that i was in bed probably
by like what 12 30
okay well i went upstairs at least and
i fell asleep okay
forgetting that he wasn't
playing the hide and go yes
and at some point you put him in the
suit no he got in the suitcase so he
thought it would be funny to be put in
the suitcase so i was like okay well i'm
going to joke with you and i'll zip you
up make him you know squirm a little bit
whatever it is but then i fell asleep
i fell asleep where was the suitcase
right
right down there yes you zipped him in
there yes thought he would be funny a
little bit it was we both were laughing
about it and then i fell asleep where
did you fall asleep upstairs
in your bedroom yes okay totally
forgetting that he was in the suitcase
still okay
and then
you came back downstairs this morning or
this afternoon that's when i got parked
what time
12 13 30 ish i was awake but
i totally forgot that he was in the
suitcase
he can tell you there's a lot of
things that i flush
with jobs yeah he did tell me like all
that good stuff so
i just totally began to do cpr on him
yes
yes about what time this morning did you
start doing that no it was the afternoon
this afternoon because i was awake but
then i finally decided to come
downstairs at like 12
30 ish whatever it is and i was like
dude i forgot he was in the suitcase and
he wasn't moving nothing was happening
so i unzipped him
took him out and started doing cpr on
him
he was on his way over here i called you
when he got here once he got here you
called it yes okay and it like air was
coming out and he was gurgling but
i could just tell by looking at him but
you knew how to do cpr you're doing that
on your own yes okay and then the person
that was on the phone with me also i
counted with him doing and he's got no
medical he doesn't take any money i
don't know like i don't know medical
wise like i know he doesn't take any
medications whatsoever
um the only thing like i said
i don't know if alcohol had something to
do with that but we had a bottle of wine
okay all right here's i want you to sit
back down because i don't want to have
one more sip of water please go on that
first level 29 residential audible one
three there are three island day drives
i'll do what i can to get you a cup
because i don't want you to have to keep
doing that
front door
unit on the channel the cups are like
right there
right here don't talk to the ex-husband
i won't can i have a cigarette please
ma'am i can't take anything out of the
house it's on the back porch nope all of
it it's secure okay i'll try my best to
get you what you need okay maybe one of
these deputies has a pack from someone
some you know sit down and i'll try and
get you what you need okay just cut okay
i don't want you on your feet
want to talk over here
and then your first name brian b-r-i-a-n
e-r-i-a-n and your date of birth uh 5
27-75 and your child is in school right
now he's not here with you no no no he's
not in school
this will be a fun one
he's not he's starting i can't even
start with how you would explain
something like this
okay sixth grade
third grade oh third grade third grade
okay
all right so sit tight for us i'm sorry
it's so hot um maybe
the middle of that would be a good spot
to stand
so we'll take it from there i'll keep
you updated okay okay
one seven
wanna do this now
did we get that dog by any chance just
sleeping on the level
so your backyard's not fenced
okay because we put him in the backyard
and i guess he knew to
i'm sorry your dog we thought the
backyard was fenced
outside no no we we have them contained
one step and one's blind
okay okay that's why i was making sure
they were under the table
nope that's yours
so we just
wait for get the instructions on what to
do next
you got some water good okay
not right now we can't have you go and
get anything why don't you sit in the
shade
you're okay right there or maybe a
little closer here where the shade is
[Applause]
yeah
are you
okay
gonna go get me a subs
and then i said well i need to go to
that
223 now
am i able
to get hard
you said wait a minute um
[Music]
you want me to get a cigarette from him
and bring it to you
i could probably do that
[Music]
he's i was going to have him arrange
child care okay good for the child in
school
okay
um is my name on there yet
no sir if not
i need to get her on there too and him
so they're on route already probably
did anybody call
no you want me to call oh
i thought you were calling
all right let me get homicide
all right
okay let's see
hold on i'm still on let me
it's natural you're nervous
you have your anxiety you're scared
right
i could tell you this
i'm going to be here just as long as you
are
including my
[Music]
it's going to be a while
i'm welcoming this race right now it's
kind of warm
all right so just bear with us
all right
let me look at my computer see
[Applause]
we already got a detective on his way
he's on the screen
okay
[Music]
[Music]
honey that's my corporal let me pick it
up
hey sarah
you get enough water
no if you want to stay seated don't i
don't want you getting lightheaded
so remember i said the detectives were
going to come out and talk to you and go
from there
you know what i'm saying
they're here they're going to ask you a
few questions and then go from there
okay all right all right sir my name's
chelsea my partner scott
um
it's my understanding you reside here
yes okay is it just you
um
your former husband okay um but you
reside here with george and then your
son lives with you or lives there's 50
50. yeah okay um
[Music]
um
she explained
last night that you guys were drinking a
bottle of wine
and around midnight
um you decided you guys were 30th yeah
okay
you guys decided to play hide and seek
well we were playing hide and seek and
then
was your son home at the time or okay
okay
um
decided to play
we're just stupid like that like sure we
were putting puzzles together we were
doing artwork you can see the puzzle
that we finished in there and then the
artwork and then
decided to play hide and seek just being
stupid okay so
he decided to get in the suitcase so i
thought it would be funny too and he was
laughing about it too
to dip him up in there i go upstairs and
fell asleep
so this morning when i
this afternoon i actually got up out of
the bed i thought for sure he was
downstairs on the laptop because he was
being
really quiet
but then i came downstairs and i'm like
where is he like
and then
that's when i found it okay
um
i don't know what happened
okay and then you weren't sure about if
you woke up this morning
it was afternoon i mean i was over this
afternoon but i just didn't want to come
downstairs so i just laid in the bed for
a little while and then i eventually
came downstairs and was confused about
where he was and then i was like oh my
god he's in the suitcase still so i
pulled him out and i stretched them out
and i started to try to do cpr upon it
i called you guys well i called brian
okay and then i
as soon as he got here which is 30
seconds down the road
i called you guys okay and the person on
the phone had me do the compressions
particularly and count with him and
until you guys showed up okay
and um
so as a part of our investigation
we obviously have to go inside the house
we have to look at things
are you okay with us going in the house
and looking at things okay um
okay
and forensics so we have to have our
forensics crime scene investigators come
out are you also okay with them coming
inside taking photographs and okay
okay can i ask is ryan
i'm sorry george was he diagnosed with
any kind of medical history not that i
know uh
not that i know of i don't know i mean
he doesn't take drugs i mean we'll have
the occasional bottle of wine here and
there but i don't know
what's gonna be my next question so you
guys don't normally drink you just drink
once in a while or well i'm gonna say
like
okay i guess normal drinking is like we
will have like the last one or two like
all of our cooking dinner
coming here and we'll play a board game
with him
but i mean it's not like
a couple of beers a day is
[Music]
and were you guys together all day
neither of you left the apartment
yesterday i think you drove up to the
financial store
okay
but i mean you can walk there does does
he have any history of any drugs i know
he doesn't know because he said he
doesn't but
as far as you've ever known him you've
never
seen him no
i mean he's from philadelphia and he
grew up in philadelphia and then he went
to massachusetts and then from
massachusetts he came down here so i
don't really know
like a whole lot of like medical history
how long have you guys been together um
almost four years like three and a half
years you guys been living here the
whole time
okay
he's never been to the doctor or
to the hospital during that time
um
he had he and his brother got into a
really bad argument at one point he had
to have facial reconstruction
but he had been in the hospital from
that and then i talked them into going
to see like a regular position to get
just like a regular like checkup thing
but there were no red flags how long ago
was that
the surgery or
[Music]
two
[Music]
is it normally stored down there did you
guys travel recently no he was going to
start
donation
in there so that's why that's why it's
out yeah okay you guys didn't recently
travel somewhere or anything like that
after you zipped them up did you move
the bag around the mess with them at all
or you just zip it up and walk away
was he sitting on his rear end and his
head up and he just kind of
[Music]
we were playing understandably okay so
he said that i needed to tell you guys
about his family like who do i talk to
about we're gonna do that once we once
we walk through and see
yeah
his family
have never liked me i'm the blue eyed
white devil is what they call it
so
they've never liked me they've never
taken the end they've never accepted me
i'll put it that way
have you called any of them um we talked
to his daughters yesterday no i mean
like about this is that okay
so no one's gonna know until we will be
making that notification so that's gonna
kill me okay do they live local yes
they're down the road they're going to
kill me
his kids are going to kill me
they're going to kill me this was not
intentional okay they're not going to
understand that they're not going to
accept it
we're going to do a
thorough investigation and we will we
will take we will definitely
make sure that you don't feel scared
when we leave okay
nine year old
well he's at school he's with your
husband i know one ex-husband your
husband said that your ex-husband said
he made a reason to not will be picked
up
all you have to do is get their
attention if you if you have a question
you need to talk to us he's standing
right there she'll be right here yeah
okay but will you guys tell me like so
you're telling me like
you you won't
call whoever it is without telling me
right i mean i have all of their phones
we're not calling we're not making phone
calls we're actually going to speak to
them in person
we'll address all of that okay before we
leave okay this was
thank you
just stay seated okay sarah i know
you're panicking okay just relax we'll
come and talk to you
we'll keep checking on you
foreign
they're coming out now i'll get you
somebody
uh she wants to say something
[Music]
what's called an is yeah that'll be
first thing tomorrow morning i'll know a
lot hopefully a lot more tomorrow
morning as far as
him
um but i cannot
there's no way i could say
how why
so just by looking at him like why is he
purple
oh that's just that's normal when
someone presses away
as soon as the heart stops bleeding
to the lowest points of the body
i'm like really scared i want you guys
to know that
you have all these definitions so while
we're here nothing's going to happen to
you before we go make any notifications
you'll have plenty of time to leave or
do it right
whatever you need to do
okay
and we can talk about that more like but
yeah
but like i don't like this was totally
like
not
intentional like
that's what i'm scared about too like
okay
[Music]
his age
no no real medical history
for him to have passed away
i know
we come out and do an investigation the
medical examiner's office will be
sending people out this is what we do if
he was 75 years old and had a history of
heart condition
we wouldn't be here i just don't know
what his i don't know what it is exactly
and that's what we're here to find out
we're just here to get the answers
the answers that you want the answers
that his family is
i mean i know i can't go anywhere but
right yeah
so do i just like sit out here and wait
for you guys if you would yes
there's anybody else having to show up
or everybody's here that needs to be
here
uh my team's here that needs to be here
the medical examiners will show up when
we call them but we're not ready for
them yet so they're gonna take him
they're gonna take some photos take him
but that's towards the end of it um and
they'll be called well in advance when
we're ready for them but we're not ready
for them at this point so we won't be
calling them quite yet
okay
so like i said i gotta go do some
paperwork
they're gonna chat
um with some people and then we're gonna
come back and talk to you if you're okay
with that um so just give us a little
bit more time um like i said i need to
go and do that and he's gonna go through
so
but can you guys tell his family
like today or after tomorrow
you have to
once our investigation is pretty much
complete here we once we leave here we
will be going to but again you'll know
you're not going to just
go and do it without you knowing you'll
know
we'll talk to you prior to doing
anything like that but how i mean i
understand what you guys and how you do
it and you know
so but like what do you just tell him
what do you tell his parents like what's
the reason why we tell them what we know
at that point yeah we tell them the
truth
and that we're going to be waiting for
the autopsy results and i will be at the
autopsy in the morning
and
hopefully the doctor will be able to
give me some of what they think and see
we'll give them their number they can
contact them and get it from them
so yeah they're gonna they're gonna know
what we're here what
you know what we're investigating and
that we're still they're gonna kill him
they always have said that they've
always always always have said that
i told you it's because i'm the
blue-eyed
white dragon that's what they call me
because they don't want him with me
so he's basically just not really been
around his family because he chooses me
over them
even after i have encouraged him
numerous times to go over there to his
family
[Music]
do you have somewhere safe that you can
go tonight
both my parents are deceived my
grandparents are deceased my aunt and
uncle are deceased i got nobody i have a
brother that's in the marine then i've
got another one that's in jail
unless the brother that's marine is he
local no
well he's
in altamont but i think he's doing
whatever marine thing he's doing
but the only way your phone's inside
correct yes does he have a phone
no he doesn't know he used my phone he
uses your yeah we okay
so
the only way the only place i could go
is over to brian's house so i don't
think he'll have a problem with it okay
so
well like i said we're not gonna leave
here if you do not feel safe you're not
gonna leave here with you not feeling
safe because then we're live and then
his exo fight in philadelphia
well she's in philadelphia but yes
shit
there's gonna be a funeral
right
that you're talking like days and weeks
no i'm
so let me do my investigation let me go
do this paperwork that i'm talking about
because we can go back and forth about
what it's like all day long i know sorry
i promise we're not gonna leave here for
you and you not feel safe okay
[Music]
i don't even know what to tell you it's
okay just take a seat have some water
give us a few minutes let us do our
thing and we'll be back to talk to you i
promise
let them know okay
thank you okay thank
[Music]
you do you have anyone in here
there's nobody here it's just me okay
that's fine you can you're right there
right yeah sit there and take care of
mine i have relief coming so just
[Music]
you